كان هدفك دائمًا هو جعلنا
نوعًا متعدد الكواكب ، نعم ، إنشاء
مستعمرة على المريخ الليلة
، كشف النقاب عن المركبة الفضائية هو أن
نقطة التحول في تلك المهمة ، نعم
أعتقد أن هذه هي المرة الأولى التي نمتلك فيها
أجهزة حقيقية لشيء
قادر  مع القليل من التطور لكونك
شيئًا يمكن أن يخلق
مدينة مكتفية ذاتيًا على سطح المريخ وقاعدة
على القمر ، قلت الليلة أنك
قد تطير أشخاصًا خلال عام في هذا
الشيء إذا استمر التطور في
التحسن بشكل كبير ، فأعتقد أنه
يمكننا  من الممكن أن نرسل أشخاصًا إلى
المدار قبل نهاية العام المقبل ، كما
تعلم في غضون عام تقريبًا
، لم تضع سبيس إكس إنسانًا في الفضاء ، لكن
كيف ستفعلون ذلك في غضون عام
جيدًا وسنضع الناس في
المدار قريبًا ونحن  سوف ينقل
رواد فضاء لناسا في
غضون ثلاثة أو أربعة أشهر على الأرجح إلى محطة الفضاء ،
نعم في تلك المرحلة ،
غرد مدير ناسا جيم
بريدنشتاين أمس قائلاً إنه
متحمس جدًا لأبو  في حدث اليوم ، لكنه
قال أيضًا إن الاقتباس التجاري
تأخرت سنوات عن الجدول الزمني وحان وقت
التسليم ، هل اتخذت Commercial Crew
Osos قابلاً للتبادل ، ولكن كيف
استجبت لذلك وهل أخذت
ذلك كتاريخ جيدًا أعني أولاً وقبل كل
شيء  في الفضاء ، هناك مدافئ
خلفها حسنًا ، إنها حقًا مسألة
تحدث نسبيًا عن أيهما
متأخر ، وبالتالي فإن معظم العمل
المطلوب من الآن خلال رحلة
رواد فضاء ناسا عبارة عن سلسلة طويلة من مراجعات السلامة ،
لذا فهي ليست متعلقة بالأجهزة حقًا
وهي حقًا  الذهاب بأسرع ما
يمكننا تحقيقه إذا كان هناك طريقة
ما لتجاوزه ، سأجعله أسرع ، فلنتحدث عن التمويل الذي قلته في الماضي أن المركبة الفضائية
ستكلف ما بين ملياري دولار وعشرة مليارات دولار
ما زلت تبحث عنها  عند هذا السعر ،
أعتقد أنه نعم ، حسنًا ، حسنًا ، النطاق الكبير ،
أعني أعتقد أنه ربما يكون أقرب إلى اثنين
أو ثلاثة ،
فإن 210 هو أنه بسبب التبديل
لسرقة التبديل للسرقة أمر أساسي تمامًا كما
تعلمون
أعتقد أن هذا قد يكون أفضل
قرار تصميم اتخذته على الإطلاق ، لا يمكنني
التفكير في قرار أفضل ، لكن الصلب
أخف من ألياف الكربون وهو
حل أو أخف من
محلول الألمنيوم ويكلف 2٪ من تكلفة
أزمة المناخ  لقد رأينا احتجاجات في
جميع أنحاء العالم هذا الشهر يقودها في الغالب
شباب مثل فريد أتون بيرج ،
هل الغضب العام يزيد من
إلحاح ما تفعله يا رفاق هنا
جيدًا ، أعني أنني أرى حقًا ما نقوم
به هنا على أنه صنع  الحياة متعددة الكواكب
بدلاً من الهروب مما أعتقد أن
99٪ من مواردنا يجب أن تركز على
التأكد من أن المستقبل على الأرض جيد
ولكن أعتقد أن 1٪ على الأقل من مواردنا
يجب أن تكون على جعل الحياة متعددة الكواكب
وتوسيع نطاق الوعي ليشمل
الآخرين  الكواكب على حد سواء للسبب الدفاعي
المتمثل في الحفاظ على ضوء
الوعي في المستقبل
وكذلك المغامرة ، والإثارة التي أجدها
شخصيًا أكثر تحفيزًا من
الدفاع عن الحجج ، لذا تفضل
كن متفائلًا
وليس متشائمًا ، أعني أعتقد أن
الإثارة والمغامرة والشعور
بالاحتمالية بشأن المستقبل أمران
مهمان للغاية ، وإلا فإنني
أعيش